Ariel Helwani covers Mme better than
anybody and working for the mothership
Ariel let me start thanks for joining us
let me start with the fight itself
was this a good fight thank you for
having me back on Dan I really
appreciate it first off I thought it was
a good fight
I thought it was compelling I think
everyone knew what was going to happen
if you would have told me before the
fight that you had seen it already and
it went into the championship rounds and
then you have asked me who won I would
have guessed Habib and if you would have
told me you know how how how he won I
would have guessed yeah of course it was
with wrestling I think some people were
surprised by Connors takedown defense
but his Achilles heel has always been
his wrestling or lack thereof and his
cardio or lack thereof and I think both
those things were on display on Saturday
was it a good night or bad night for UFC
it was a tremendous night who's saying
it was a bad night don't listen to you
know Dana's Dana's doing the whole sad
dad know he's so disappointed in
everyone if this fight gets made again
in six months rest assured all that
footage and then some will be used
you know there's talk of hubby being
stripped of his belt none of that is
going to happen yeah he might get a slap
on the wrist yeah he might get a
suspension or a fine six-month
suspension something like that but let's
not forget this is a guy who fights
every six to nine months so even if they
give him a suspension what is he really
losing out on this was the
second-highest gate in UFC history the
highest in the state of Nevada and by
all accounts it's going to smash all
their pay-per-view records it was an
incredible night for the company
what did Conor make off his fight he
said that he stands to make around fifty
or so million you know a dream of his
has always been to make nine figures for
an MMA fight I asked him last week
before the fight if he stood to make
that he said he was halfway there so not
quite what he made for the Floyd
Mayweather fight but 50 million if you
would have told me five years ago that a
fighter in the UFC was going to make 50
million for one fight after the
pay-per-view numbers come in and
everything like then he gets a cut of
pay-per-view I would have called you the
biggest liar on earth I mean that's just
fabula I don't think the entire UFC
roster is making 50 million combined
outside of Conor McGregor so this was a
very good night for him as well and in
true Connor fashion he's not hiding from
this he's not going you know into a dark
place he's not licking his wounds he's
already calling for a rematch because
hey he's that kind of a competitor and B
he knows how much more money tends to
make in the rematch I was curious about
this when you had the post-fight fight
and you know where Habib goes into the
audience the camera angle all of a
sudden you know there was morality here
with mm or with a UFC where they went
way way high above instead of covering
it like it's an event because remember
when galata was hit Riddick Bowe they
Jim Lampley did play-by-play of the
fight via BM the melee in the ring
that's what I was surprised at it felt
like wait a minute this is in front of
you and they had an overhead shot where
they weren't focusing on what was
happening you know this is spectacle why
that's why I love you so much you are so
smart you get it other people don't do
you know why then because that's
state-run TV the UFC is producing that
that's pro wrestling they don't want you
to see behind the curtain and I couldn't
agree more with you
I rewatched that Bogle at a fight last
night and in particular the coverage and
I thought Lampley was phenomenal and all
of that and just being absolutely honest
my problem with the UFC and their and
their and their coverage on television
as far as the events for years has been
it's dishonest a year ago I made this
huge think about a guy named Al Jermaine
sterling who was brutally knocked out
they never showed him on the mat it took
him ten minutes to get up they never
gave us an update afterwards they never
told us how he was doing they never told
us that he was discharged and that's you
know a small example but it's because
it's dishonest they want you to see what
they want you to see just like Vince
McMahon wants you to see what he wants
you to see so in that moment this isn't
Mike Breen doing play-by-play of Ron
Artest running into the crowd which is
what you should do they are going as far
wide as possible and telling you as
little as possible and and and and I
don't like that I feel like in 2018
Broadcasters need to start actually
covering the events like they would an
NFL game NBA game etc but unfortunately
because the UFC controls all the
production I'm not surprised I'm very
happy that someone like you who's you
know say I'll say like a novice MMA fan
notices that because that's unlike
anything else in any other sport
unfortunate our sport it's still run
like pro wrestling yeah but who's gonna
be offended by this I mean you're
watching you have seen thank you this is
what you pay for don't you oh it's not
so much being offended it's just that
they don't want you to see it so it's
the same thing when someone is coming
off a year-long suspension for steroids
they won't tell you the real story as to
why he was away they'll just say he was
out of action for a year you know it's
all through rose-coloured you know say
it again same thing and I'm though I
hate the comparison system to be in the
sense that you know I would get all
fired up in April I was getting fired up
when people were saying like although
the Brooklyn incident with the bus was
you know scripted that wasn't scripted
and I think you saw on Saturday just how
personal this thing was but the way they
present their show and the way they shy
away from talking about the truth is it
is to me a very big problem in 2018 the
audience is smart enough and you saw
that on display on Saturday night
because they kept going further back
further further back do not show you and
and then look everyone has cell phone
footage everyone saw it eventually I
think it makes them look bad for trying
to hide it so what happens next well
what happens next is that Nevada will
probably you know give a bead some kind
of punishment fine suspension but it's
not going to be anything drastic he is
not going to get stripped and and and
Dana said afterwards that you know
anyone who ran into the cage or threw a
punch if if any of those people are on
the UFC roster and some are on the UFC
roster they will be cut well to that
I'll say why you didn't cut anyone after
what happened in Brooklyn and there were
people on the UFC roster who are you
know involved in that incident at the
Barclay center with the dollies and the
chairs to being thrown at the bus so you
can't do it now you know everyone on
this Monday morning wants to blame
someone they want to blame Habib for
jumping over they want to blame Connors
training partner Dylan Dennis for
yelling at him they want to blame Conor
for throw
punch they want to blame clubs training
partner for punching connor guess what
everyone's to blame from April to
October everyone is to blame everyone
has some sort of part in all of this
from from the way this was promoted to
the talk about religion and family and
and Russian politics everyone was to
blame you cannot be surprised for what
happened on Saturday this was very
combustible and so at this point they
just need to move on accept it and at
some point I would not be shocked if
they do the rematch and I would
certainly not be shocked of all this
footage that everyone is claiming to be
so upset about is used heavily in the
promotion for that rematch well done
Arial good to talk to you again thanks
for joining us as always my pleasure
anytime Ariel Helwani
covers the sport for ESPN for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]